[موسيقى]
ام
تحيه طيبه مشاهدي الكرام
الا يعلمون الجنديه السوريه ان من يتخلى
عن سلاحه كمن يتخلى عن شرفه
فلماذا تخلي النظام عن شرف سوريا العسكري
المتمثل بسلاح الردع الكيماوي من اول عكسه
امريكيه
الا يعتبر ذلك بموجب القانون السوري خيانه
عظمى
لماذا تبخرت الممانعه والمقاومه والصمود
والتصدي بسرعه البرق هل ما زال بامكان
النظام ان يتهم معارضيه بالخيانه والعماله
بعد ان قاد بقائه في السلطه بالتخلي عن
الاسكندرون اولا ثم الجولان ثم السلاح
الاستراتيجي الان
كيف يتشدق النظام بالسياده الوطنيه
والكيماوي اعطى لامريكا والجولان لاسرائيل
والقرار العسكري لايران والسياسي لروسيا
يضيف اخر
لماذا عبر او لماذا اذا عبر المواطن
السوري عن راي بسيط
يتهمونه بانه عميل للموساد ويمول الارهاب
وعندما يتنازل النظام عن الشرف العسكري
يكون وطنيا خالصا
يا سلام الا تخجل ابواق النظام من تصوير
التخلي عن الكمار على انه انتصار عظيم
هل يسلم سلاحه
الا المهزوم
لكن في المقابل اليس تسليم السلاح
الكيماوي خطوه حكيمه جدا رغم قساوتها
اليس بديل ها عدوانا امريكيا يحرق الاخضر
واليابس
وقد يؤدي الى انهيار الوطن تماما اليس
التخلي عن الكيماوي اهون واشرف من تسليم
البلد لحفنه من الامراض الساريه والمعديه
والجرثوميه الاخطر من الكيماويه من امثال
المعارضين السوريين و اكلي لحوم البشر
وقاطعي الرؤوس اليست السياسه فن الممكن هل
كان بالامكان افضل من مكان ثم اليس لدى
سوريا من السلاح التقليدي اقوى من السلاح
الكيماوي كما قال رئيس الوزراء السوري
اليوم
اسئله اطرحها على الهواء مباشره على عضو
مجلس الشعب السوري السيد شريف شحاده وعلى
العقيد عبد الحميد زكريا الناطق باسم هيئه
اركان الجيش الحر نبدا النقاش بعد الفاصل
ام
اهلا بكم مره اخرى مشاهدي الكرام نحن معكم
على الهواء مباشره في برنامج الاتجاه
المعاكس بامكانكم التصويت على موضوع هذه
الحلقه هل تعتقد ان النظام السوري يمكن ان
يتنازل عن اي شيء لامريكا واسرائيل كي
يبقى في السلطه صوت على صفحه الاتجاه
المعاكس حوالي اه او اكثر من ثمانيه
وثلاثين الفا اربعه وتسعون فاصله واحد نعم
خمسه فاصله تسعه لا السياسه العقيده لو
بدات معك بهذه النتيجه ما الذي يجعل اكثر
من اربعه وتسعين في المائه من المصوتين
نسميه المشاعر ونحن بالمناسبه ليس مسؤولين
عن النتيجه النتيجه تعبر عن المصوتين فقط
ما الذي يجعل هذه النسبه اربعه وتسعين
يعتقدون ان النظام السوري مستعد ان يتنازل
عن اي شيء في سوريا حتى سوريا كي يبقى في
السلطه باسم الله الرحمان الرحيم وسيعلم
الذين ظلموا اي منقلب ينقلبون
سيدي الكريم مقاومه وممانعه النظام السوري
وشركائه هي ليست الا كمقاومه العاهرات
وممانعه البغايا على فراش الرذيله والخنا
وهذا النظام يمتلك فلسفه سخيفه جدا يستطيع
من خلالها اقناع محبيه بان هذا الهزيمه
والعار ليست الا نصل الى هيا وقد ابتدا
هذا الامر هو مسلسل التنازلات هذا ليس
وليد هذه اللحظه بل هو قديمه قدم هذا
النظام ابتدا في السبعه وستين عندما كان
حافظ الاسد وزيرا للدفاع واعطى اوامر
بالانسحاب وتسليم اراضي شاسعه للعدو
الصهيوني عبد الرحمان الدكتور عبد الرحمان
الاكثر كان وزيرا للصحه وكانت في مدينه
القنيطره لحظه اعلان سقوط هذه المدينه فت
طلب وزير سابق قال له يبدو ان هناك خطا
كان في هذه المدينه فاسم اه كلاما نابيا
وادرك ان
سيطره وغيره طبيعه الامر الاخر من يذكر
الرائد مصطفى خليل في كتاب سقوط الجولان
عن ماس من الخيانه انتقل الامر الى ثلاثه
وسبعين ويسمونها حربا تحريريه وما تركوا
مدرسه او شارعا او مستشفى او ماخورا وما
الى ذلك الاسلوب تشرين التحريريه وهي ليست
الاب اكبر هزيمه عسكريه للنظام لقد سبق
لها نزار قباني يعني خازوق دق باسفلنا
من جبل الشيخ الى سعسع نعم واكثر من ذلك
لقد تسلم هذا النظام اكثر من واحد واربعين
بلده وقريه ولولا تدخل الجيش العراقي في
اللحظه الحاسمه لك ان الجيش الصهيوني ليس
في دمشق ويمكن ان يكون ايضا
يذكر في مذكراته عن مفاوضات القوات
الاربعه وسبعين يقول كان الرئيس الاسد
يستجدي مني ان يرفع العلم السوري ولو
للحظه واحده في القنيطره والتقصف بعدها
وقال له انني مستعد للتوقيع على هذا
الاتفاق رغم ما فيه من شروط مجله فقط
اعطوني مترا مربعا واحدا ارفع فيه العلم
ليكون تبرير
اكثر من ثلاثه الاف وخمس مائه شهيد طبعا
نسال هل من حق نظام التخلي عن هذا السلاح
وغيره قانون العقوبات العسكري السوري في
الماده مائه وخمسه وخمسين تقول من سلم
سلاحه معلومات العدو عن مصدر الاخيره وما
الى ذلك يحكموا بالاعدام حسب القانون
السوري
قانونيه
بهذه الحاله وليست كلمه هي قليله عليه
بالمطلق هذا النظام سيدي الكريم لا يفهم
الا لغه القوه بوجود تهديدات حقيقيه
تتساقط كل الاوراق حتى ورقه التوت فمن منا
ينسى كيف سلم هذا النظام عبد الله اوجلان
الاشقاء الاتراك عندما طالبوا به من هاتف
واحد فقط اسلموا الانسحاب من لبنان اسراء
جريمه اغتيال الرئيس الشهيد رفيق الحريري
تصور جاءت اوامر من الرئيس الى وزير
الدفاع بالمغادره غدا صباحا من لبنان طالب
وضابط القوات الخاصه وانا شاهد على ذلك
منه ان يتم التاجيل فقط اربعه وعشرين ساعه
من اجل تدريب الضباط العرض العسكري معين
ما يقوم به الاخوه من اللبنانيين وقال
الاوامر غدا صباحا وخرج الجيش السوري
ذليلا صاغرا من لبنان ممتلئه سيارات ه ب
ما خف حمله وغلا ثمنه من من مسروقات اهل
اللبنانيين امريكا تطلب من هذا النظام
الرد خلال سبعه ايام على المقترح وهي
توافق خلال 7 دقائق من خطه النظام بكل
تاكيد
سيدي الكريم من يرهن سلاحه الاستراتيجي
على اتم الاستعداد على ان يرهن شرفه
التكتيكي عرضه العمليات بكل تاكيد النظام
رغم ذلك يحاول ان يزرع في نفوس شبيحته على
انه نظام يقدم لهم كل شيء في سبيل بقاء
وبقاء هذه الدوله بقيه دوله هو اليوم بشار
الاسد يهم شعبه بانه سيار بن عمر وتعلن
هذا الرجل الذي راهن قوس وعند
مقابل الف بعير خدمه لقومه او بيضل نفسه
بانه حاجب بن زراره التميمي الذي عندما
تميم ذهب وراهن قوس وعندها مقابل اموال
طائله وان يرعى بلوث مين في مضارب
العرب في حينها بان حاجب بن زراره عن
العرب جميعا اما بشار الاسد فهو مستعد
الايراني ليس سوريا بل العرب جميعا من اجل
ان يبقى لحظه واحده في كرسي حكم اكثر هذا
النظام تضحياته دليلا في ايام رخائه كانت
جاريه عندما لان طهران وفي ايام شدته يعود
كلفه ابقى الى اسياده من اشقائنا العرب
هذا النظام سيسلم ال كنا وما بعد بعد
الكيماوي باختصار هذا النظام ينطبق عليه
في الهجاء ما جرته نفسي ولكن في الهزيمه
كالغزال
اه
بدنا ن هذا الشريط السيده
التي نسمعها
بس خليني بس اعطيك سؤال يعني الرجل يقول
لك عن اعاده بناء الى سبعه وستين اه احدث
احد الباحثين الامريكيين يقول مخطئ من
يعتقد بان مصر هي اول دوله عربيه توقع
معاهده السلام مع اسرائيل ان اول من وقع
معاهده السلام مع اسرائيل هو النظام
السوري في عام بعد الف وثلاث بعد حرب
تشرين مباشره قال انها كانت معاهده سلام
كامله الاوصاف غير معلنه بدليل ان على مدى
اربعين عاما لم تطلق رصاصه واحده على
الجناه كيف ترد
انا بدي اسال
سعيد انه قدمتها المقدمه اه في صوره
المعارضه تريد ان تقدم نفسها على انه ما
حصل في سوريا هو تسليم الكيماوي بمعنى
انه تسليم للكرامه الكرامه لم ترتبط في
يوم من الايام لا بسلاح بس انت بتسموا
اللي بيسلم سلاحه في سوريا حسب القانون
السوري كمان يسلم شرف
اولا هناك مصالح عليا للدوله يفرضها واقع
الدوله هذه نقطه النقطه الثانيه سوريا لم
تسلم سلاحها الكيماوي
الى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه سوريا
وضعت السلاح الكيماوي تحت رقابه دوليه وفق
مبادره روسيه
تسلموا الجميع يتحدث عن تدمير
اثنين اثنين هذا السلاح الكيماوي ليس هو
حاله الردع الوحيده التي يمكن ان تكون
للدوله هناك صواريخ واناس احدثك بشيء يمكن
قليل من يعرفه سوريا قبل ان توقع على
الاتفاقيه او قبل ان يصير هناك تنسيق في
هذا الموضوع كان لدى سوريا اسلحه قد وصلت
من روسيا هذه نقطه النقطه الثانيه كما قلت
لك حاله الردع ليست هي حال الكيماوي وانا
اقول لك كل العالم يدرك ان السلاح
الكيماوي بعد فتره من الزمن يصبح ب انا
على الدوله فنحن اتخذنا قرار يشار الهم ال
ال بصحبه
مال وهو يحتاج في الحد الادنى الى عشر
سنوات في الحد الادنى يقولون سنه او سنتين
هناك تقرير عسكري صدر يقول ان تدمير
السلاح الكيماوي يحتاج الى ثلاثين عام
ويحتاج الى مصانه ويحتاج الى دول على
شاكله روسيا وامريكا وبريطانيا وفرنسا
والمانيا يعني على كل حال انا اقول لك ليس
اه هذا التسليم هو حاله يعني نادره واضف
الى ذلك عسكريه لا يمكن استعمال السلاح
الكيماوي عسكريا هناك اسلحه بديله لكن هذا
السلاح كان يمكن ان يعمل في فتره بين
ثمانين والتسعين
الفكره هذه والسلاح النووي الاسرائيلي لا
يمكن استخدامه لانه اذا استخدمته اسرائيل
ستقضي على المنطقه الكامله سيد شريف انت
تعلم ان الكيماوي والنووي هي اسلحه
استراتيجيه ل لردع والتخويف ولا تستخدم
عندما تتخلى عن سلاحه الكيماوي والله بكره
اي دوله مجاهل افريقيا
في صواريخ بالستيه قوتها التدميريه اكثر
من قوه الكيماوي بالاف المرات وانا ساقول
لك الكيماوي لم يستخدم على مدار التاريخ
العالمي الا مره واحده حتى المانيا عندما
غزاها الغزو الالماني عندما دخل اليها لم
يستخدم السلاح الكيماوي اه ضرب العدو وهذا
يعني ان السلاح الكيماوي لا يمكن
منع استخدام الكيماوي اللي هو
لا تستخدمه ضد الاعداء فلماذا استخدام
اولا عندما نقول نحن ان هناك مجموعات
ارهابيه اتت بغاز السارين انت تقول او
المشاهد يقول
الجماعات اللي بدي اتفق مع الجماعات
الارهابيه هي التي استخدمتها صحيح
طيب بما انه الجماعات الارهابيه هي التي
استخدمت السلاح الكيماوي لماذا تقومون
بتسليمه انتم لماذا لا بدي اسالك سؤال
هناك او ليش انتو تاخذوا
انه ما استخدمته ماستخدمته الارهابيين
التكفيريين الوهابيين هكذا هم يستخدموا
طيب تخلوا عنه انتم ان يستخدموا اللبناني
الشو اسمه والتكفيريين هناك هناك اتفاق
بيننا وبين روسيا وروسيا حليفه لنا اقترح
الروس بالاتفاق معنا ان يقوم الجيش السوري
او الحكومه السوريه ووضعه تحت رقابه دوليه
خليني ارجع لك عنها لانه نقطه امريكا
صديقه اسرائيل من الروح للروح هل اسرائيل
ستتخلى عن سلاحها النووي اذا كان قانون
الامريكان
يتخلى عن سلاحه من اجل الروس انا عندما ان
تتخلى من اجل الروس عن سلاحه من تخدم تخدم
اسرائيل
يا دكتور انا لدي مصالح عليا اليوم ان
اتحدث معك بكل صراحه قلت لك ان السلاح
الكيماوي ليس هو حاله الردع الوحيده وقلت
لك سوريا استجابت المبادره الروسيه روسيا
تقف مع سوريا منذ بدايه الازمه وهذه
الاستجابه امر طبيعي ومنطقي في ظل تعاون
سوري روسي اثنين سوريا لديها منظومه
صاروخيه اقوى من كما هو قال هذا الكلام
الوزير رئيس الوزراء اليوم
ثلاثه انا اقول لك لم يستخدم الكيماوي
لانه يعني الحاله دمار شامل في المنطقه
يا اخي يا اخي انا هادي هادي عندك في بيتك
روسيا
ودائما انتم حتمي بها الروسي يعرف انه ما
راح تستخدمها بس هي بتحمي والكيماوي يحمي
بلد انت تعلم ان الكيماوي هو السلاح
النووي اب تاع الفقراء لماذا ت تخلى عنهم
الله ليس لديه نووي وليس لدي الكيماوي الا
يشكل حاله ردع ضد اسرائيل اثنين انا عندي
هذا القلم استطيع ان اكتب فيه واستطيع ان
اضافيه الحاله الثانيه اللي استطيع ان
نكتفي استطيع ان هذه اكثر استطيع ان اكتب
اكثر استطيع ان نجعل الشخص الذي يكتب عليه
يعمل لايام وايام انا اقول لك بكل صراحه
بكل صراحه انا اقول لك الحكومه سوريه
تصرفت تصرفا منطقيا وعقلانيا اتجاه هذه
الازمه كان المطلوب سوريا كان المطلوب ان
تنهار القذائف الامريكيه على سوريا هل
اذهب الى لجنه البلد اما ذهب الى تسليم
القرار الذي هو يصبح عليه
سياده العقيده اسم على هذا الكلام قد يكون
التخلي عن الكيماوي اه مؤلما جدا و قاسيا
جدا على السوريين نظاما وشعبا لكن لكن على
القياده في لحظات حرجه ومفصليه وتاريخيه
ان تفكر بمنطق وليس بلغه العنصريه ايهما
افضل وهذا الكلام الشريف الحادي ايهما
افضل ان
احرق البلد عن طريق تعريضها لعدوان
ما هو لي اللي هو الامريكي انت بتعرف
عندما يطلب الامريكان ستنهار البلد سيتفكك
الجيش ستذهب البلد في ستين الف داهيه هلا
فعل ذلك ام انا ور بالتخلي عن هذا السلاح
ايهما اهم التخلي عن الكيماوي ام سوريا
سوريا اهم
الكيماوي يكشف كذبه اخرى من الافات النظام
وزير الاعلام السوري خرج وقال انه لا يوجد
اي حدث كيميائي اليوم كما يروج معارضه بعد
ساعات قال ما حدث ليس الا فبركه من اجل
خداع اللجنه بعد ساعات اخرى قال نعم يوجد
استخدام السلاح الكيميائي ومن قام به هم
كما يسميه يسمونهم الارهابيين ولا ارهاب
في سوريا الا ارهاب النظام فيما بعد خرجت
علينا مسلمين الشعب ان بقصه لا يمكن لعاقل
تصديق جابوا اطفال من اللاذقيه
الدكتور
بالروايات الانجليزيه
وغيره
رحله شيقه طويله اه من اللاذيقيه جمع
وهنيك وبعدين عليهم او حتى في ناس ماتت
معهم سيدي الكريم ليس كما ذكر ضيفك بانه
اشراف للسلاح على السلاح بل هو تدمير وتنص
الاتفاقيه على ما يلي عدم حيازه لهذه
الاسلحه او تخزينها او الاحتفاظ بها او
نقله لاي جهه سواء مجموعات افراد عصابات
دول الى اخره الامر الثاني تدمير كلمات
خزينه الدوله الامر الثالث تدمير مرافق
انتاج هذه الاسلحه الامر الرابع منع
العلماء والخبراء والتقنيين من اي انشطه
اي تدمير هؤلاء والنظام السوري ابدى
استعداده لكل هذه الامور بما فيها البند
الرابع واسلم اسماء من يعمل بهذا الملف
الى كل الجهات المعاهده الدوليه يا سيدي
هي مع المنهزمين هي ليست الاك دخول الحمام
والاستحمام لا يمكن لك ان تستحق الا بعد
ان تصبح عاليا تماما يعني برايك بتتخلى عن
السلاح سلاح يعني تماما اه التكفيري ان
يقوم يعني البعض طالب ابو حمد ان احد
النشطاء يقول لك كنا نسمع بعصر الكشف بس
ما سمعنا بعصر الشرح مثلا
هم يتهمون التكفيريين بما في ذلك هل يعقل
اننا نقتل اطفالنا من اجل ان نخدع للجان
الدوليه نحن لا نؤمن بكل المجتمع الدولي
فليس هذا المجتمع الدولي متخاذل الجحيم
نقطه من اجل ذلك هذا هذا هو الامر الاخر
هم يقولون باننا نحن استخدمنا ويقولون عن
تقارير صحفيه بتركيا عن اثنين كيلو من
التقرير يقول استخدام مائه وعشرين لترا من
ماده السارين
فقط الاخيره هم يقولون بان استجاب
المبادره روسيا رئيس كذبتهم وقالت هذه
المبادره قدمتها لنا سوريا ونحن ساعدنا
عليها فقط ليس المقداد اتصل بالوكاله ال
ال الوكاله الكيماويه العالميه وقال
ارجوكم تبعثي لنا ستساعدون تماما على
التلفزيون ال اه حتى ناتي الى فكر التجنيد
البلد من الدمار سيدي الكريم بين خط
اوباما الاحمر الذي يمتد الاف سنه ضوئيه
وبين خط الاحمد بشار الاسد امام كرسيه
حكمه غرقت سوريا في الخارج من الدماء
والدمار ان اساس والان يوما اسلم
التسليم الكيماوي ام تسليم عاطف نجيب
الثوره ليفعل به اهل ودعمها
اليوم افضل ماذا بقي في البلد اصبحت ي
يدمر اعطى تقرير هو ليس بحديث هناك تدمير
اكثر من اثني مليون المنزل تدمير الكلي مع
عدد مماثل جزئيا تدمير الفين واربعمائه
مدرسه ثلاثه الاف من مائه مسجد عشره كنائس
من بينها كنيسه ام الزنار في حمص الف
ومائتين وخمسين مشفى ميداني وثابت هذا
التدمير تم خلال مائتين وثلاثين صاروخ
سكود من خلال ثلاثه وثلاثين الف طلعه جويه
دعني اتوقف هنا هذا الرقم سته وثلاثين الف
وهو رقم من حوالي اسبوع وهذا الرقم موثق
من من مصادر عديده بينما
ثلاثه وسبعين في بدء الحرب عندما كانوا
يحقق الجند السوري الاتصالات رفض ولو طلعه
جويه واحده لمؤازرتها
الاختصار اه من يريد الحفاظ على بلده يرفع
الحصار عن ثلاثه مليون انسان سوري محاصر
اليوم ياكلون التراب في كل من القوطه
بعدين تقوم لماذا يخافوا من امريكا حتى
مثل ما تنمحى وليد المعلم كما اوروبا
الامر الاخر هي اقول لك من غاب عن فاصله
اسال عن عمله وكان هذا الرجل ليس من هذا
البلد المعطاء هو ليس من بلد شكل القوات
او من بلد يوصف ازمه ساختم في دقيقه واحده
ارجوك
من منا لم يسمع به في في عام الف وسبعمائه
وثمانيه وستين لويس الخامس عشر ملك فرنسا
اشتري جزيره كورسيكا من من اماره ولم اسال
جنوده لاستلامها رفضوا وقاتلت كل
القلعه واحده عندها طلبه مع التفاوض
الفرنسي المتفاوضين اذا قالوا لاننا اسلحه
اكثر من ستين تدمير كم فقالوا لهم نحن
ننزف القلعه بنا وبكم عندها وافقوا كانت
الشروط على الشكل التالي
نحن اهل هذه القلعه نطلب الخروج مع
اسلحتنا ونقرا طبول مصر وان يؤدوا جهودكم
من التحيه العسكريه وانت بدون ما تم
تقديمه وعندها تمت اتفاقيه وفتح باب
الطلاق خرج منها رجل واحد فقط هو من تبقى
من القلعه وادله جهود فرنسيين وعاد ما ما
هدمه رجل واحد يبني ولا يهدم وطن وامام
انا بسالك بس دقيقه مثل المساله انتقلت
دائما تقولون ونؤكد انه انتم لعلاقه لكم
بالكيماوي وانتم تريدون تجميد سوريا وان
تشريفات حاجه اول مظاهرات قلت نحن نريد ان
نحافظ على الدماء السوريه والى وكذا فقال
لك الاخواني اللي بده يحافظ على سوريا ما
بيقتلوا مئات الالاف من السوريين وما ب
يحاصر ثلاثه ملايين وكذا وكذا والامر
الاخر بالغوطه بالارهابيين رشوهم
بالكيماوي بما انها الارهابيين هم اللي
رسوم بالكيماوي ليش ما عملت ولكن يومين
حداد على ارواح الشهداء الغوطه مثل ما
عملت ومثل ما طلعت هادول الفنانين ضد
العدوان ال ال الامريكاني في قاسيون لماذا
لم تعلن و ا الحجاب على الاقل على
المواطنين السوريين الذين ماتوا على ايدي
الارهابيين في الخطه لماذا لماذا وزع تم
الحل
لا لا لا هذا الكلام غير دقيق غير صحيح
هؤلاء الذين استشهدوا في الغوطه مسجله
اسمائهم لنا مركز الشهداء في في في دمشق
العاصمه السوريه ولهم حقوق الشهداء لانهم
فعلا استشهدوا على مجموعات ارهابيه انت لا
تريد حقيقه انت لا تريد ان تصدق ان هناك
مجموعه
اليابان اقوال سوريا اليابان ليس هناك
عصابه في اليابان اسمه اوبيك وهاجمت خطوط
الانفاق في اليابان ووضعت الساري
وقامت الحكومه اليابانيه لمده عشره اشهر
في محاربه هذه المجموعات وغسل المناطق
التي اه اه
يعني انا هلا نحنا موضوع انه انتم تضعون
ال الحق على الارهابيين وخلاص قليلا من
التفكير معك انا بس انا بدي اسالك مثل ما
قال ال على موضوع الان التنازلات انتم
الان بدات م بالكيماوي في الصحافه الغربيه
الان بدؤوا يتحدثون عن وجوب تجريد سوريا
من اسلحتها الجرثوميه ومن ثم ننطلق الى
تجديدها من الصواريخ التي تتبعونها انتم
بها ورئيس الوزراء تبعها اليوم بها طيب
البعض يقول انه اه يعني تخلي سوريا عن
سلاحها الكيماوي هو اشبه ب راقصه
الاستراتيج او عرضت تعرف انت شايف انا
شايف انه اه
اول شيء بتبلش تخلع ملابسها قطعه قطعه
انتم بلشت هم بالقطع الاولى وشوي شوي راح
تتعرض
المناوره الروسيه بالتخلص من السلاح
الكيماوي اشبه بعمليه السيفتي السياسي حفل
التعري مثله وعندما تخلي عرضه الاستربتيز
حماله صدرها ستخلع بعد بعد دقائق من ا بس
اخرى وانت تعرف لو
النقاش هذا النقاش يخرج عن المنطق هناك في
الدوله المصلحه عليا تسمى مصلحه الدوله
بشكل عام ينظر لها هذا من هذا الطرف او
ذاك من هذا الطرف هذا ما بيهمنا نحنا
بيهمنا مصلحه سوريا اليوم هناك عدوان على
سوريا اصبح مبيتا من قبل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هل تنزع هذا العدوان ان تسمح له
تحت ذريعه الاسلحه الكيماويه
والله انا من
[تصفيق]
ان تدخلت في عمليه السلام
2 ماذا سوريا من الاتفاق اولا
وقف العدوان الامريكي على سوريا الذهاب
الى جنيف 2
ثلاثه جعل المنطقه خاليه من اسلحه الدمار
الشامل هذا يعني ان الروس بداوا يعزفون
على الناخب الاسرائيلي
الامنيه
يوم من الايام تستطيع اسرائيل التخلي عن
النووي بيقول والله اذا فيه
عندي سلاح اضافي
اليه السلاح السوري وهذا اتفق عليه بين
سوريا وروسيا عندما يقول لديك العربيه على
نمط نبيل العربي لا تقف الى هذه الجامعه
مع الدول العربيه انت لا تستطيع ان تقاتل
بمفرده
وكل العرب وقفوا معك
من يمول الان المعارضه في سوريا السعوديه
وقطر وانت تعلم ذلك نقطه رئيسيه اولا
غالبيه الشعب الامريكي يرفض العدوان على
سوريا
خليني بموضوع التنازلات موضوع
عندما جاء كولن باول الى سوريا قبيل
العدوان الامريكي على العراق جاء بمجموعه
شروط وسوريا رفضت كل هذه الشروط ثمانيه
شروط
رفضته الان انت ليش ما تتعلموا من صدام
حسين ليش ما تعلم ومن القذافي القذافي
سلمهم حتى سكاكين المطبخ للامريكان ورجعوا
صدام حسين عن نفس الشيء لماذا تسير
ليس لمصلحه سوريا الان الدخول في حرب
لماذا قبل هذا كان يطلع على
يقول لك بدي دمر امريكا واسرائيل دقيقه
والعرب
الناس
الواحد
اقول لك ليس من مصلحه سوريا الدخول في حرب
مع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه امريكا
دوله عظمى انا انا جنب شعبي وبلدي واهلي
الحرب اثنين هذه الحرب تختارها الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه في الزمان والمكان
واقول لك اكثر من ذلك تجنب الحرب اصعب من
خوض الحرب خليك ولذلك اقول لك اوباما اذا
كان قويا في اعلان الحرب وهو الحائط جائزه
كان له ان يكون اقوى ل ومنع الحرب على
بدي انتقل اليك بسرعه الان الان المعارضه
تقول هل ما زال بامكان النظام ان يعين
المعارضين وكل من يقف في وجه ولو بكلمه
واحده ان يعيرها بالعماله والخيانه بعد ان
تخلى عن شرف سوريا طيب انت تعرف سوريا
العسكري ليس مرتبطا اه ب بموضوع كيماوي
ولا بصاروخ الشرف العسكري هو ان تبقى انت
ثابته
سوريا سوريا اذا واحد حكي كلمتين تعمله
عميل للموساد اليورانيوم الارهاب
انا
تدخلات على سوريا لا لا ليس شرف سوريا
مرتبطا بالسلاح الكيماوي هناك نقطه اعلى
من ذلك هي مصلحه الوطن وعندما تريد ان
تذهب من اجل الكيماوي الى تدمير سوريا سوف
يدمر الكيماوي
لذلك انا علي ان اختار
واقل الضرر
عندما يتحدثون عن الرئيس حافظ الاسد وانت
تعلم وانا اعلم ان الرئيس حافظ
اعلانها حرب تشرين التحريريه
وهو ما نسترجع القنيطره وهو من قال الجيش
السوري قاتلوا في حرب استنزاف تسعين يوم
ولم توقع سوريا على معاهده الاستسلام وانا
الذي استغرب كل العرب يعلمون ان سوريا لم
توقع حتى
وان الحرب التي تشن على سوريا مقاومه
قرارها ومقاومتها لاسرائيل لا لا الان
الان انتم على مدى اربعين سنه ترفعون شعار
الصمود والتصدي والممانعه والمقاومه
ومواجهه اسرائيل ولا معك انا معك الان بعد
ان مثلما قلق بعد ان تعرض
دقيقه دقيقه
ماذا تقولون للشعب السوري الذي دقيقه
لاحظتم عليه اربعين سنه
الممانعه
اولا نحن حتى هذه اللحظه ما زال يشكل
اعاقه للمشروع الامريكي في المنطقه
على معاهده السلام بذاتها سوريا مع
اسرائيل 12 ليس تسليم السلاح الكيماوي
معنا ان سوريا انتهت هناك صواريخ
استراتيجيه بالس هي موجوده
اه يعني ما زال السياسيه سياده العقيد
ننتقل الى ال ال ال الجانب الاخر البعض
يقول بكاء البعض ودموع التماسيح لما يسمى
بالمعارضه السوريه
ما بدنا نقول شويه قويه اه يعني بكائه
والقول بانه انت مسلم تم الكيماوي وتخليتم
عن شرف سوريا العسكري ومن هذا يقول تسليم
الكيماوي اهون و اشرف مليون مره من تسليم
البلد لحفنا من الامراض الساريه والمعديه
والجرثوميه الاخطر من الكيماويه امثال كذا
كذا كذا كذا كذا كذا كذا امثال اه اكلي
لحوم البشر وقاطعي الرؤوس وغير ذلك من هذا
الكلام اسالك سؤال بدي اسال استراتيجيا
استراتيجيا انتم تقولون الان انه والله
بسوريا المواطن السوري بيحكي كلمتين
تعملوا عميل الموساد وما بعرف شو بيقولوا
بيت وما بعرف شو وانتم كذا كذا يا اخي
الان الان فكر بالمنطق السياسه فن الممكن
هل هناك بالامكان افضل من مكان قال لك
الرجل وهو عضو مجلس شعب ممثل للشعب السوري
اه قال لك نحن لسنا قادرين على مواجهه
امريكا كلام منطقه كلام عقد يسمعون هادول
اللي بيطلعوا بيطلعوا على التلفزيونات
السوريه بدون يحرقوا السعوديه وبدو وبدو
يحرقوا جنوب شرق اسيا وبدا يحرقوا شتم
فريق البخاريه
اقاموها بدو يضرب تسعه الاف وثمانمائه
وثلاثه وعشرين اثر اليوم صاروخ على كذا
وبعد الكلام كله صريح يقول لك هذه الحكمه
وهذه كذا مقاومه وكذا وحكمه طيب انت شو
بتقول له تماما تماما اولا يقول ليس من
مصلحه سوريا انتحار بامريكا و نسال هل من
مصلحه النظام السوري ان يقتل شعبه يتحدث
عن صواريخ بالستيه هذه الصواريخ تم
تخطيطها بين بيوت المدنيين
فهل يتباهون به بهكذا صواريخ جميل الامر
الاخر هم عندما يقول نحن سلمنا هذا الامر
لمصلحه سوريا لماذا لم يقولوا اننا نوقف
القتل والتدمير من اجل مصلحه ابناء سوريا
لماذا لا يقولون نحن ن نسلم ال ال السلاح
الكيمياوي مقابل اعاده اعمار البلد مقابل
تعويض اسر الشهداء مقابل معالجه والجرحى
رغم اننا نحن لا نوافق على هذه الاتفاقيه
بشكل مطلق بكل تاكيد
اما ما ذكرته من معارضين فانا اقول
وبصراحه ونحن لا يجب ان نكون ابواق النظام
نخطا ياهو اثاما اننا يجب ان نعترف ي كل
شيء يبقى صوره تبقى سوريا مستقبل سوريا
الحره مستقيمه اقول ما ابتليت الثوره
السوريه بمصيبه اكبر من كوريا المعارضه
هذه والبعض بشيء لحتى النقطه عن ال عن
الضاد
الثوره السوريه لم تكن ثوره يتيمه لا سند
لها تحسب بل كانت ايضا ثوره عقيمه اجهزه
على ان تولد قاده ورجال الحقيقيين يتقدمون
الصفوف يرفعون رايه النصر عاليا ويطرحون
لتحافظ الاجزاء على هذا العلم جميل خليني
بالموضوع نعم الموضوع هو يتحدث على ان
هناك بقيه تحديث سلاح سوري باشراف روسيا
وما الى ذلك وهم
ايران وحزب الله انهم معهم انا اقول لك ان
زواج المتعه بين ملالي طهران وبين ثانيا ت
النظام في دمشق وما نجم عنه من طفل خطيئه
واقصد حزب الشيطان قد انتهى لا بل قد شمله
الى قوات دين النظام في من كل من بوتين
على لافروف سيدي الكريم حزب الشيطان لندن
بوش في هذه الازمه لماذا لان ابو او يدخل
في سر داده وهناك لايجاد ها
اعلامه يروج بان النظام السوري حقق انتصار
الهيا وليس انتصارا عاديا هل تعلم ماذا
يفعل حزب الله اليوم انه يفتشوا الجنوب عن
اي صاروخ يمكن ان يطلق على شمال فلسطين
ونتذكر عندما وصف الصواريخ الذي اطلقت ب
2009 على اسرائيل الصواريخ المشبوهه واخر
بانطلق وصار وقالوا دخيل الله ان ما لي
علاقه تماما اما بالنسبه لايران فانا اقول
لك ان المناجاه الشيطانيه بين ملالي طهران
في سراديب هم وبين النظام السوري وهو في
سرداب وطاقه
ان تخلي طهران عن هذا النظام لا بل راحت
تعترف صراحه ان النظام هو ما استخدم
الكيماوي تعليقا على كلام رفسنجاني وقالوا
واثبته مره اخرى كذلك الامر رحبت ايران
بانضمام سوريا الى هذه الاتفاقيه
اما ان العلم ان ايران تفوق على سلاحها
النووي من عشر سنوات ولم تتخلى بينما
سوريا تخلف بسبع دقائق هذا هو السؤال
يستفاد من هذه المعاهده بعد قليل روسيا لن
تكون قالت نحن نكون جزءا من اي مواجهه
عسكريه على الاطلاق وقد مضى الزمن الذي
نقاتل فيه دفاعا عن الاخرين كما تخلوا
مسبق على صدام حسين وعمليه لم يقاتلوا مع
فيتنام عندما كان هناك شيوعيه بسوريا
تماما
الراسماليه اما النظام نفسه فهو يقول نحن
لن نوافق الا بنزع الاسلحه الشامله من
المنطقه كلها فلماذا لم يطالب ال اسرائيل
الا اللهم اذا كان وليد المعلم اسرائيل
الكيان الصهيوني من هذه المشكله
وقال نحن لن نوافق الاب وقف التهديدات
الامريكيه وفي كل امريكا ويقولون الخيار
العسكري الموجود على الطاوله ولكن يجب
اننا اتهم النظام بهذه الاتفاقيه لان هذه
الاتفاقيه يجب ان تعرض على مجلس الشعب وقد
رفضها وانت تعلم
انا اتمنى وجود عضو مجلس الشعب الذي قال
له الوطن العربي قليل عليك انت لازم تحكم
العالم نقول له تسليم الكيماوي قال يا
عليه ان ثلاثه مسلم كل شيء بالبلد بس
دقيقه هادي
مسرحيه ضيعه تشرين
دير بالك اه اه
يرحلون في مسرحيه ضيعه تشرين هذا
ينقل عنده كلمه شهيره نقلتها تبدل على
الفيس بوك
ونحنا منتصرين
ومش حاسين على حالنا طلع الحرامي بدو راس
المختار اصلا بس احنا طلعنا اشهر عطيناه
الكرم ونفذنا ولكن عدد من ايام ان يعين
الزفت هكذا يقولون لكم في الفيسبوك بدي
اقول لك يعني ب ضيعه تشرين العدو كان
بالدراسه المختار فقال نحن نعطيه المختار
خلينا نعطيه الكرم وهكذا في سوريا نحن
اعطينا ياخذ البلد انا انا
ولكن من يريد ان يكون شرف بلده يرفض
العدوان على بدو
يدعون جزء كبير من المعارضه السوريه
استدعت الامريكي ورحبت به وطالما ان تحكي
المكشوف انا اقول لك من يستدعي الاجنبي
الى بلده لضرب بلده كما يستدعي رجلا الى
زوجته مائه في المائه وهذه هي المعارضه في
جزء كبير منها استدعت الامريكي الى قصف
سوريا قبول سوريا بالمبادره على الموقف
الامريكي وكشف الى الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لا تتطلع الى المعارضه بل تتطلع
الى مصالحها ومن
اين المعارضه لتقف الان وتقول ان اسرائيل
الان ان الاسرائيلي الافضل والاسوا
امريكا
على المعارضه ان تقول انا اختلف مع النظام
ولكنني اقف ضد الضربه الامريكيه على وطنه
ياتي هذا يؤكد ان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لا تقيم وزن للمعارضه سواء كانت
هذه المعارضه في الداخل ام في الخارج
هذه المعارضه بالنسبه ل لامريكا لا لا هم
لها سوى مصلحه اسرائيل الثلاثه
الاتفاقيه اجبرت الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ان هناك قطبا اخر في المنطقه في
العالم هو الروسي نحن انشانا قطب جديد هو
الحب الروسي لذلك من يريد ان يقول ان
سوريا سلمت سلاح وكشفت بلد انا نصر على ان
اقول لك لا يا سيدي سوريا تجنبت دمارا
شاملا
واجرت للعالم كله
الدوليه
السوري على الفيس بوك يقول لك اول مره
بشوف واحد سلم اسلحته لمن يمانع هم ويقوم
هم ماذا تقول له
انت اليوم
كمواطن لمصلحتها الثاني بينزل لمصلحته
هناك دوله تنظر الى المصلحه العامه تنظر
الى شؤون الناس انا اقول لك الولايات ان
هل مازال هناك دوله الدقيقه هناك
هناك سياسي انا والله مش عم بس
هناك كاريكاتير وزعه قبل ايام مرسوم
القرار السياسي في سوريا بيدرس والقرار
العسكري بيد ايران والكيماوي صار لامريكا
والجولان لاسرائيل ويتحدثون ويتشدق الى
السياده الوطنيه
[تصفيق]
الرئيس الاستقرار على مجلس الشعب مجلس
الشعب ومجلس الشعب هل توافق على
هذا المرسوم ويعرض على مجلس الشعب الان في
عمليه مرسوم اصلا هذا الاسم يخرج من مجلس
الشعب ومجلس
صلاحيات رئيس الدوله كونه هو رئيس
الجمهوريه العربيه
نحن ننظر الى مصلحه عليه انا اريد ان اسال
سؤال الولايات المتحده الامريكيه قامت
قوتها لكي تتقاتل الاتحاد السوفياتي في
ذلك الوقت مع حلف وارسو وعندما رفضت صدام
حسين قامت امريكا بضرب العراق واحتلاله
وانشات الكيماوي الاسف الى تدمير البلد ام
الى تجنب البلد للمصائب والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تريد ان تفرض الحرب الان في
الزمان والمكان
امريكا بشيء صحفي امريكي يقول بالامس انت
تقول لي نحنا امريكا
الصحفي الامريكي يقول ماذا نطلق الصواريخ
على نظام الاسد اذا كان قد استسلم من اول
عكسه امريكيه فلوس علنا يعني هو عمله
الامريكي رفع حواجبه هيك سلم كل شيء اخر
انا بالسياسه السياسي اضحك على من اريد ان
يجنب بلدي المشكله الاخر يضرب راسه بالحيط
ما عندي انا في عندي حرب اخوضها في الزكاه
اخذها في الدهاء اخوض في السياسه المهم
انا جنب شعبي الماسي والدمار
الذي دمر تربع سوريا بعد بيحكي
كم من الفجور يرتكب باسمك ايها الشعب
شعبيا سيدنا
السؤال الاول هذه الدول الموجودين احنا
فيها قطر والسعوديه هل كان يعيش الشعب
السوري هذه الازمه قبل ثلاث سنوات كان
سوريا عم الراحه والطمانينه السلام الى
الامام والاقتصاد الجيد والمشاريع الضخمه
ان الدوله رائده
الارهاب والارهابيين وانت يا سيدي جبهه
النصره والقاعده موجودين في سوريا
موجودين اسرائيل وتركيا وقطر والسعوديه
موجودين في سجون النظام ايضا كانوا واطلع
كل اللي طلعوا بالعفو الاخير في سوريا
كانوا الجماعات
السياسه العقيده العقيده كيف ترد على هذا
الكلام كلام الرجل يقول لك انا من حقي ان
استخدم كل شيء من اجل الانقاذ البلد انت
تقول انه الواحد
انا قبل ما هذا بدي بدي شو اسمه بدي اسالك
سؤال يعني اه دقيقه دقيقه اثنين ذات يوم
شخص ذهب الى بلد بعيد وعندما عاد تسال
واصدقاءه ما دفع الاشاعات هناك قال في ذلك
البلد اسمه بلد الاقوى اما يغتصبون او
يقتلون فقالوا له فقالوا له وانت ماذا
فعلوا قال والله قتلوني وهذا انتوا بسوريا
لا احد يستطيع الاقتصاد السوري
لا
لا لا لا لا
هناك انتم تريدون ان نقول نعم لا نريد
الموقف الامريكي ثم تاتي امريكا حتضرب ثم
نرى
يا اخي ملعون الف مره اللي بيطلب من
امريكا
اكثر من نرجع لنقطه
من حقي بالسياسه من ان تلجا الى كل شيء من
اجل تجنيب البلد لاخر نهار باخر النهار لو
ضربت سوريا قبل ايام قال ان ضرب سوريا قبل
ايام سوريا الان اليست سوريا الان بوضع
افضل بالف ميه وخمسين الف هذه وخاصه
امريكا معلومات كامل لضرب
تخلى عن كل هذا مقابل
الكيماوي يستطيع ان
وهو وصل موجود وراح ما صار عند حزب الله
عند العراقيين
لماذا وضع النظام السوري نفسه في الزاويه
بعد ان قتل اكثر من مائه وخمسين الف شهيد
و سلم ليس الكيماوي يسلم كل شيء على
الاطلاق هو يقول بانه لولا دعم قطر
والسعوديه ما كان تحالف سوريا السوريين
هكذا اليوم فعلا لولا دعمهم لك ان نصف
الشعب السوري قد مات اليوم هذه هذه
الاتفاقيه سيدي الكريم من خدمات اطرافا
عديده خدمت كل من امريكا ومن وراءها
اسرائيل خدمت روسيا روسيا تريد لهذا
الرئيس ما يسمى برئيس البقالي 2014 لا
تبذل العالم ان منكسره مازومه خدمت ايران
لان استطاعت تاجيل البحث في موضوع ها
النووي ولو قليلا انا
قوه ان هذه الاتفاقيه ليست لخدمه شعبا
ووطنا انما يا خدمه الكرسي وان بشار الاسد
على اتم الاستعداد
انسانيه اخرى على هذا الكرسي وجلس عليه
عاريا
معقول نعم فقط في في في ملاحظه سريعه جدا
بالنسبه للمعارضه انا اطمئن انما في سوريا
بان من سيحكم سوريا المستقبل ليس اولئك من
يسمون انفسهم بمعارضه وهم جاؤوا وهم ازلام
النظام بل سيحكم سوريا امثال هؤلاء القاده
هذا ابو عيسى الشيخ الذي قبل النظام
الثمانينات وفقد اليوم اربعه من الاخوه
الشهداء وفقدنا وعشرات من ابنائه عن هؤلاء
القاده الذين سيحكمون سوريا ونقوم على
الجميع بان الصوره ستكون في اعياد امينه
دقيقه بس امريكا واسرائيل لا تخشى ان على
الشعب السوري من السلاح الكيماوي بل
تخشيان على السلاح الكيماوي من الشعب
السوري لهذا تريد تجربه منه لو كانوا
صادقين في انهم يريدون حمايه الشعب السوري
لماذا لا يقومون بتدمير منظومه الكيماوي
الكامله والتي تشمل السلاح الكيميائي
وساعات ايصاله من طائرات وصواريخ ومدفعيه
وذلك الراس والخميس المجرم الذي عمر بذلك
خليك شويه سيد شريف كلام موثق من قبل
المعارضه طلبت امريكا قبل فتره من
المعارضه سلمونا الكيماوي ونحن
على مساعدتكم المعارضه لم تتوصل مش عم
بقول لك انه الوطنيه لكنها لم تستطع اتخاذ
قرار تسليم الكيماوي فجيت انت ما شاء الله
وسلمت تقول لهم انا
برنامج جورج قرداحي
المعارضه المعارضه ولدينا معلومات جزء
كبير منها خمسه وتسعين بالمائه وافقت على
ضربه امريكيه ووافقت على تسليم السلاح
الكيماوي ووافقت اكثر من ذلك على اعطاء
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه كل الاماكن
الاستراتيجيه في البلد لد امريكيه وخمسين
على
امريكا يا سيدي كما ترى على اسرائيل انا
اقول لك معروفه للمعارضه المعارضه السوريه
في الخارج مستعده انه تشرح من اجل ان تصل
هذا الكلام
[تصفيق]
المعارضه
يستطيع حزب الله
قوه ردع صاروخيه واستطاع اجبار اسرائيل
على
الوقت
من اراد ان يغادر حافظ بشار الاسد الحكم
هو من طالب طائره الى غير رجعه وقاد
الكثيرين سوف يغادرون وسوف نذهب الى اجراء
انتخابات عندها الشعب من يخرج موجه من
يقرر سؤال اخير يقول لك طيب لو تنازلت هم
خمسه بالمائه من التنازلات التي قدمتها
للقاصي والداني
السوريه
اعطيت ولو تنازلت هم خمسه بالمائه تنازل
تم لروسيا عطوها كل التفتيش ابعد الناس عن
النفط اعطيتهم لامريكا الكيماوي اعطيتم
خمسه في المائه
لا لا لا اولا الازمه في سوريا ليست ازمه
شعب مع حكومه ابدا انا اقول لك لافروف قال
نحن نعرض على الرئيس الاسد وكثير من
الاشياء يرفضها الرئيس
الاختصاص
اقول ولد هذا النظام عاريا لقيطا من رحم
الخطيئه وسيعود عاريا الى مزابل التاريخ
كما جاء واختم بالقول اه العرب يتساقطون
الواحد تلو الاخر فالاول ولا هاربا
والثاني في السجن صريحا والثالث محروقا
منبوذا والرابع مفضوحا مقتولا وسيكون ما
يسمى بشار خامسه على مرفوعا
هل تعتقد من الشعر يا سيدي الله يخليك
هل تعتقد ان النظام السوري يمكن ان يتنازل
عن اي شيء لامريكا واسرائيل كي يبقى في
السلطه النتيجه لم تتغير اربعه وتسعون
فاصله واحد نعم يمكن ان يتم الاحزاب
الشموليه
انتهينا يا جماعه بعد ان وقت مشاهدي
الكرام لم يبق لنا الا ان نشكر ضيفينا اه
السيناتور اه شريف الشهابي عضو مجلس الشعب
السوري وسياده العقيد عبد الحميد زكريا
نلتقي مساء الثلاثاء المقبل فحتى ذلك
الحين ها هو فيصل القاسم يحيكم من الدوحه
الى اللقاء يعطيك العافيه
[موسيقى]
ام